what I have for you today is going to
come as a huge shock to some people it
certainly shocked me I found out this
weekend about what is possibly the
longest-running Khan played on the David
Pakman show in in the show history of
the show over the years we've received
voicemails that have sort of stood out
we had for example turkey burger lady
who left a voicemail which has become a
cult favorite with completely no context
leaving me a recipe a very detailed
recipe for how to make a good turkey
burger here's a sample of that voicemail
do you love turkey burgers but you're
never quite sure how to make them well
now I can tell you how to do it it's
easy
first just top the burger with one slice
of cheese and heat it until a cheese
melt I'm assuming you've already made
the turkey burger part then what you're
gonna want to do is spike some
mayonnaise uncut fries and roll okay
very good one another time we had an
Irish version of Jordan Peterson : I
call it that it was Jordan Peterson with
a slightly to Irish sounding accent the
clip very popular warning me about Joe
Rogan take a listen to that one oh hi
this is Jordan B Peterson calling in I
just wanted to call because I heard the
exciting news that you might be on the
tour wrong can podcast later this week
so congratulations on that and just
wanted to call and also say take you
know make sure you study up before you
go on there because I did it myself and
um I didn't have all my ideas entirely
coherent in my head that was another
interesting voicemail that a lot of
people like then we had how could we
forget the source audio for the David
Pakman show dubstep remix contest which
was all spurred by this song that was
left on our voicemail one day the David
Pakman show it's my favorite show you do
more good than you know the David Pakman
show
[Music]
that led to like a dozen or more remixes
in an entire other contest that we did
now over the weekend I was contacted by
someone claiming that they did all of
those voices and many more their name is
Simon Wynne held and I admit I was
skeptical because these are all over the
place could one person really be doing
all of these over a period of years and
I never noticed so I asked Simon I need
you to send me a single recording where
you do all of these different voices or
a bunch of them and he did turkey burger
lady and all take a listen to this hot
David this is fresh Nelson but turkey
burger lady did you end up cooking a
turkey burger how'd it turn out I just
want you all to know I'm developing a
cooking show
gold it's not my diet but I just had to
try it today we're gonna cook a special
French delicacy you may have heard of it
croissants our celebrity guests are
former president William Jefferson
Clinton and Arnold Schwarzenegger hey hi
y'all hey David this is Bill Clinton has
ever big fan of your show y'all do great
work keep it up ha keep it up David this
is Arnold Schwarzenegger former Governor
of California
I just want to remind you to watch my
classic movie kindergarten a cop it's
great I break a pencil with my thumb it
would help you to learn to be less of a
girly man you both are just selling we
invited quasi pseudo-intellectual Jordan
Peterson and it's too busy on his next
book 12 more rules for life he sure is a
stickler for rules at least when it
comes to life I'm writing a third book -
even more 12 rules for life it's absurd
sure where did you come from go away
today's show is booked our last guest
it's a young man named Simon who wants
to share a song hand it Simon okay
the David Pakman show it's my favorite
show you do more than you know is that
conceited I say no the David Pakman show
[Music]
well that song was very interesting okay
this is Trish nelson of it's not my diet
but I just had to try it signing out
yeah so anyway really amazing stuff
great work there are a bunch of other
callers that Simon has done over the
years fake ted cruz and a whole bunch of
others it was one person all along now
because people will ask this has nothing
to do with Troy York
Troy York is an actual right-wing
antagonist that calls in with racist
characters like a black character named
Jamal Jenkins a Hispanic character
called Ramon Ramos that's how he
pronounces it
none of those Troy York characters have
anything to do with Simon I don't want
Simon pulled into that you can check out
Simon's work on Instagram at Simon
underscore Morris underscore win held
really really great stuff and it turns
out that it was it was a con job all
along
nice job Simon very very nice privacy
calm is one of our sponsors and they're
giving you five dollars just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacies of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create
twelve virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company
and I know I won't be charged in the
future if you're ordering food over the
phone why do I need to give a restaurant
my real card number I don't have to
companies don't have to know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free they
do have a paid version with different
tiers where you can create more virtual
credit card numbers per month cash back
rewards extra security features but go
ahead and sign up for the free service
it's a no-brainer companies can't charge
you unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy comm slash Pakman